devastating effects of climate change
happening right now and on a massive
scale there are fires raging across
europe they are fueled in part by
extreme heat and extreme drought the
pictures on your screen are from greece
where hundreds of people have been
evacuated and back here in the u.s more
than a hundred a million americans are
under excessive heat warnings and heat
advisories providing a blistering
backdrop to new climate change measures
just announced by the white house let's
get straight to nancy chen who has made
the smart choice this morning and is at
a new york city public pool in astoria
queens looks pretty good there nancy
good morning
good morning to you tony i definitely
the smart choice here and people were
out here trying to cool down until the
absolute last minute yesterday new york
city is one of many places under a heat
advisory today and it comes as bone dry
conditions and record high temperatures
have fueled at least 86 large fires
across the country this month alone
over the course of a couple hours our
whole lives changed it was like driving
through a tunnel of flames severe heat
is fanning flames nationwide with
several fires in texas where parts of
somerville county have been burned to a
crisp the health of our citizens and our
communities is literally at stake
as above average temperatures engulfed
the u.s president biden issued that
stark warning wednesday and promised new
executive actions to combat climate
change including a 2.3 billion dollar
investment to build climate resistant
infrastructure but he stopped short of
declaring a national climate emergency
we need to act
we just take a look around
here in new york some sought refuge from
the heat at cooling centers like this
public library in brooklyn where we met
brooklyn resident clyde taylor i don't
have no ac in my apartment so i came
here to cool off it is too hot
i would have to wait for the sun to go
down
to go home our main concern is we want
people to stay cool especially
vulnerable new yorkers christina farrell
is with the city's emergency management
department which is now overseeing 550
cooling centers even as some like 69
year old lawrence posner decided to
brave the outdoors this is ridiculous
this heat there should be no work
air conditioning water
television
sleep that's it
and at the public pool in astoria park
folks like jahira rivera her daughter
november and her new friend were
grateful for an evening soak it was
really hot and it was actually
refreshing to be in the water today it
feels like i could get in the pool and
get some air
a good idea there and new york city will
be sweltering through at least the
weekend the heat advisory has been
extended through sunday night and the
city's emergency management department
says it is keeping a close eye on the
power grid they are imploring everyone
to adjust their air conditioning by only
a couple of degrees to make sure the
power stays on for everyone named
if you hop in that pool don't forget
your floaties nancy thank you